okay it's gonna be a challenge it was
really hard to focus towards the end of
that last game were you actually blind
to the night if you couldn't already see
yeah I guess I was blind to other things
other than the night okay
so let's turn back on speech okay good
luck
last time oh I'm playing Sam Sam
Chappelle okay good luck goodbye and
let's play I'm gonna play super
aggressively I just play d4 well I meant
to play E for let's put you for delay D
for Best Buy test maybe ooh
caro-kann unexpected Carol calm let's
play the fantasy variation it's called
the fantasy variation because it's
White's fantasy to control the entire
center play Knight c3 at some point I'm
gonna be very aggressive I'm waiting for
life to take the pawn not sure if I
understood all of that missive what this
of e6000
the goal is to win as quickly as
possible which I pre move f4
also who is number two tastier Danny
wait what see tasty for okay that was
probably that was probably the Danny
wizard probably not tog II let's take a
pause oh this is so pleasant
there's a bishop on e6 it's slightly sad
I just want to take black has to develop
f5 ooh
f5 let's take a bishop god it takes me
six so nice wait was more than 100 bits
given Queen what clean be six also
thanks for the sub like Queen h5 Queen
e6
oh my night my night is no not Bishop e2
no my queen my beautiful queen
my queen no only uh distorted reality
okay well I'm gonna lose a queen but all
me castle ah my Knights impact upon saw
through my my cleverness let's play
Queen f3 opponents of smarts
I should have um I could have taken on
d5 yeah I should have taken on d5 I can
still take on d5 right knight c6 we're
now I'm losing track of the position I
was a bishop on e 297 Oh 5 is under
attack
wait a minute
when did I and I move my pawn I have a
pawn that for everyone for ya okay let's
play thank you Father
I'm threatening the triple fork okay so
I've done d5 Bishop on e to Bishop on c1
pawns on b5 f for weights I don't know
if I believe that I guess I'll find out
later
um long castling I forgot that was legal
Oh cuz I won the bishop oh it's equal
material actually wait long castling my
Knights attacked on this is turning into
like kind of a tricky game because I was
messing around and now I have to hunker
down
I have pawn and poncey for probably
makes sense for c4
I want to play I want to just attack on
that Queen side now like Bishop e3 maybe
I've gotta play Bishop c4 not sure if
that was tiger or the Danny wizard or
the John g5 out of nowhere
what was the g5 what is g5g fives a move
I think everyone's trolling me but I'm
not sure I'm blind and I'm confused
about this position
it was tog II really oh maybe the total
weight g5 is actually kind of confusing
what's going on let's play Bishop III I
feel like this is a grand scheme all by
tog II
what no I think time he's just talking
to himself I think just one person just
talking to themselves and before maybe
chimed in at some point
g4 okay I'm glad actually that thought
didn't take the pawn like Weena's
attacks let's play Queen f2 so it's
actually a kind of a nice setup remember
the nights are on d7 and c6 you spy on
your what your ello your ello maybe your
ello like the rating or yellow like the
color a five okay well things thanks to
the person who gave the bits okay that
wasn't tog II cuz orchestrated is a hard
word to spell almost tigey's like a bit
genius a five wait what a five okay so
my Queen wants to teleport to c7 and to
do that a five I could I'm getting so
confused there's so many different
storylines let's just Castle counseling
yeah thanks to the person even if it's
not real who gave twenty thousand twenty
seven thousand bits
wait what might be for a night before
night before
I have upon wait
I'm dine on d5 I have to move a lot
quicker to let's play a3 all my knight
is attacked on d5 okay cd5 just trying
to get through this game I see to get
some pork
Knight see - oh no I have rips one no
over Casey one because both looks could
have moved to c1 and then expecting
between takes III our 93 then Queen
takes III my Queen still wants to go to
c7 yeah and thanks to the sub thanks for
your comment it's hard when like so many
robot voices talked to me and then tigey
appears out of nowhere and then there's
biffer rook rook g8 pawns on g4 okay so
with my trucks on c1 I still have pawn
on c4 let's play Queen a7 yeah scary
move for my opponent a very scary move I
didn't even hear the clock times no that
was probably I'm guessing that was the
Danny wizard but I'm not sure
okay maybe I'll play target next my
beard on developing maybe it's what to
do Queen Queen a5 oh there is a pollen a
fabulous
Alexa tell me a joke about chess all the
robots talking to me what ha ha oh that
was good I was very good g3 wait a
minute wait a minute wait means he's
victorious thanks Alexa oh my gosh 95
ratio of John actually gave thirty three
thousand five hundred bits you guys
weren't lying also that was very chaotic
thanks so much John eclipsing eclipsing
the the other other bits people under
the Danny wizard and the tog II number
three
oh no joke no joke is a OHS mod but yeah
that's that's not a joke I guess no
you're you're number two it looks like
with that
yeah only only one person can be number
one thanks again John wait so when did
this happen
Oh Eric flaming necks I'm not okay I'm
playing I'm playing the John but where's
the John or maybe maybe that was hogging
in disguise yeah when it's biffer okay
so I can officially trust biffer for
being trustworthy
yeah thanks biffer biffer so wholesome
Wow I'm trying to scroll up but there
was something there were too many
comments I can't scroll up all the way
maybe I can scroll up I can't even
no I can't go back to see who said what
Oh Sam Oh Sam I just played Sam yeah
also Sam good job for not taking my my
queen
[Music]
Hodor okay well we'll call John Hodor
from now on yeah what is so no I read it
not doing this this would have been so
nice cuz Knight c7 guaranteed also
attacking the Queen
there's Forks everywhere Knights so
strong so so strong but I saw this move
whoa Kiyomi kiyomi's back
oh just stopping to say good night I
love you too thanks for stopping in and
thanks John for or thanks Hodor
for gifting a sub to Kiyomi twelve
thirteen Oh two subs
I thought I was being so tricky I've
been working on my acting but I guess I
have to work harder now this would have
been such a nice me too so nice
maybe this will still go on YouTube I
forgot about the people in the future
watching on YouTube this is just gonna
be such a chaotic YouTube video but yeah
people on YouTube say thanks to John and
togi
and Hodor and togi
and danny wizard and Kiyomi